ce soir programme de double jeu retrouvé
les blues brothers que du plaisir me de
l'anchoïade car de nouvelles banques
canadiennes y gars le plus pauvre de
nouveaux colis plus les 1.4 philippe
guérand les salles plage de laurent bâti
le retour de corti l'ordre platine d'or
et en invité d'honneur patrick sébastien
bonsoir
bon froid
bienvenue aux folies bergères pour
double jeu à plisser vous vous êtes très
beau je fais bien
peut-être surprise ce soir je vous vois
surpris mais derrière dix ans a été pris
d'une légère disposition passagère mais
comme dirait sabatier thiery je sais que
tu nous regarder nous te regarde on nous
regarde et on appelait thierry ardisson
qui sera bientôt papa
[Applaudissements]
ce cadre on se calme pour jouer avec
nous ce soir deux stars de la variété
française
quand il chante à nos actes manqués
c'est pour notre plaisir jean jacques
goldman
[Applaudissements]
quand il chante pour le plaisir
c'est un acte de vente et herbert dinars
et surtout votre invité de ce soir que
je connais particulièrement bien qui est
pétri de qualités qui est merveilleux
beau sensible doux un manoir c'est le
merveilleux le merveilleux
patrick sébastien il pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez
vous je m'étais un peu ce bleu